[Aplausos]
es verdad no ha sacado a pasear a su
hijo Vladimir al cementerio habla de mí
le cuesta entender la muerte para
evitarle más dolor le ha contado que su
padre está dormido el 4 de marzo fue
alcanzado por una bala mortal de un
francotirador ruso cuando salió a
comprar pañales para
vladys aquí estaba atendido mi marido no
pude recoger el cadáver tuvimos que
irnos porque temía por Vladimir y tuve
que dejarle aquí solo el cuerpo del
marido desvelana y otros 14 civiles
permanecieron esta calle de bucha por un
mes entero ahora sus vecinos la han
renombrado el callejón de la muerte
tetania nos muestra en las imágenes de
soldados rusos sacando a civiles de sus
casas Que consiguió grabar con su móvil
8 personas fueron ejecutadas detrás del
patio trasero de su vivienda
no es justo que tantas mujeres se queden
sin marido que los niños se quedan sin
padre Solo quiero que los que cometieron
estos crímenes sean castigados
no es fácil lidiar con el dolor de la
muerte sobre todo si ha sido en
circunstancias trágicas
hemos trabajado juntos toda la vida a él
lo tomaron cautivo los rusos y a mí me
dejaron libre No superen nada más de él
Hasta que vi su tumba pero más difícil
es sobreponerse a la desaparición de un
ser querido Alexandra Lleva más de seis
meses sin saber nada de su padre Sigue
esperando cada día la llamada los
servicios para buscarlos desaparecidos
durante la Guerra habiéndose mi padre
nos pidió que nos fuéramos de aquí me
dijo este lugar va a ser horrible yo me
quedaré el 24 de marzo leí en facebook
que había desaparecido lo llamé varias
veces pero su teléfono estaba apagado
desde ese día aparecen mis sueños para
hablarme
las matanzas y desapariciones de cientos
de civiles en bucha y recientemente
emisión han causado profundas heridas
psicológicas entre la población Y si no
hay justicia si no hay rendición de
cuentas el trauma perseguirá a las
nuevas generaciones